What do a back tattoo, Pulp Fiction, and Donald
Glover have in common?
They're all Easter eggs you might've missed
in the MCU.
It was the unexpected success of Iron Man
that gave Marvel Studios the jump-start it needed.
That said, it also helped that the filmmakers
sneaked in little references here and there
to a larger universe.
This includes a prop that only eagle-eyed
viewers caught – the shield of World War
II hero Captain America.
It's partially constructed and sitting idly
on Tony Stark's work desk.
In a 2010 interview with MTV, director Jon
Favreau explained that the movie's inclusion
of the iconic symbol was nothing more than
a visual gag, at least at first.
He explained,
"An [Industrial Light and Magic] artist put
it in there as a joke to us for our cineSync
sessions, when we're approving visual effects."
They liked it enough that they kept it in
the film's final cut.
In "The Incredible Hulk," Emil Blonsky receives
a special serum that transforms him into the
Abomination, a monster intended to be the
Hulk's physical match.
The container holding the serum bears a label
attributing its development to a certain Dr.
Reinstein, a name familiar to longtime "Captain
America" readers.
"Dr. Reinstein" was actually a fake name used
by Dr. Abraham Erskine, the man who developed
the Super Soldier formula that turned the
scrawny Steve Rogers into America's mightiest champion.
Interestingly, the final cut of The Incredible
Hulk could have featured more than a passing
reference to the Captain, had things turned
out the way the director originally intended.
A deleted scene actually included a cameo
of the Star-Spangled Avenger's frozen body,
preserved underneath the Arctic ice.
Aside from introducing new heroes Black Widow
and War Machine, Iron Man 2 also delved deeper
into the Avengers Initiative, exploring how
it would be executed while emphasizing that
Stark may not be a good addition to the project.
"'Prone to self-destructive tendencies' — I
was dying!
And, please, aren't we all?"
Interestingly, the scene where Fury delivers
the not-so-good news to Stark contains an
early reference to the existence of a hero
who would eventually fight alongside the Avengers:
The sequence features the two men sitting
down in a covert location and discussing Black
Widow's assessment of Stark.
Beside Stark and Fury are some S.H.I.E.L.D.
holographic screens that depict a map of the
world, with certain locations marked.
The marker that certainly got a lot of attention,
though, is one that pointed to a seemingly
secret location in Africa: The technologically
advanced, Vibranium-rich nation of Wakanda.
In the scene where Thor is proclaimed by his
father Odin as Asgard's next king, we see
their sworn enemies, the Frost Giants, making
their way through the palace walls and into
the vault where precious artifacts are kept
by the All-Father.
Seeking to obtain the Casket of Ancient Winters,
they struck a deal with Thor's trickster brother
Loki that allowed them to sneak into the palace
undetected.
However, when the invaders attempt to take
the relic, the Destroyer comes to life and
takes them down.
In the chaos that follows, the Infinity Gauntlet
is shown for a brief moment on screen.
However, as Hela casually revealed in Thor:
Ragnarok, the Gauntlet in Odin's vault was a counterfeit.
This throwaway line of dialogue was meant
to address a massive plot hole that was created
when Avengers: Age of Ultron showed the Gauntlet
in the possession of Thanos all along.
Set during the Second World War, the first
Captain America movie told the tale of how
a scrawny, bullied kid from Brooklyn was gifted
with a superhuman physique to match his superheroic heart.
Initially deemed too expensive and risky to
send out into actual combat, Captain America
soon took the lead in fighting Hitler's men.
Wait a minute — an American adventurer in
an iconic costume going up against German forces?
If that sounds familiar to you, perhaps you've
seen Raiders of the Lost Ark.
In case that connection isn't enough, there's
a line of dialogue uttered by the Red Skull
that's meant to remind you of the classic
Indiana Jones flick.
Early on in the movie, the Red Skull finds
the Tesseract in a town in Norway.
"And the Fuhrer digs for trinkets in the desert."
Avid moviegoers will likely draw the connection
between this line and Hitler's quest to find
the Ark of the Covenant in Raiders.
There's a scene in The Avengers that features
Captain America training at the gym.
Fury shows up with a briefing and an invitation
to join the Avengers Initiative.
While Fury's papers contain important information,
it's the name of the agent who prepared it
that makes it even more fascinating than it
already is, at least for comic book fans.
Upon closer inspection of the first page of
the document, the name Mephisto is in the
caption under the photo of the Tesseract.
This codename appears to refer to the S.H.I.E.L.D.
operative who helped the agency acquire data
about the powerful artifact.
However, some might have speculated that this
was a reference to the Marvel comics demon
of the same name, a malevolent, extradimensional
force who uses mystical means and trickery
to cause all sorts of mayhem in the Marvel
universe.
Over time, Mephisto became an in-joke among
MCU fans because of all of the debunked conspiracy
theories about the demon's supposed involvement
in the events of WandaVision.
But hey, at least we can say that the MCU
technically does have a Mephisto, kinda.
During the battle between Iron Man and Aldrich
Killian, Tony lops off Killian's left hand.
In Thor: The Dark World, Loki makes it appear
that he chopped off Thor's hand in order to
trick the Dark Elves.
In Captain America: The Winter Soldier, Bucky
Barnes resurfaces as the villain, with his
entire left arm missing.
In Guardians of the Galaxy, Groot loses both
arms because of Gamora, while Klaue gets his
arm swiftly chopped off by Ultron in Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Lastly, in Ant-Man, when Scott Lang disables
the Yellowjacket suit with Darren Cross still
inside it, the villain's right arm shrinks
first before the rest of him does.
In an interview with CinemaBlend, Kevin Feige
confirmed that the phase-wide Easter egg was
a nod to Star Wars Episode V: The Empire Strikes
Back.
He said:
"It didn't start out as intentional, but it
became intentional."
In one scene of Thor: The Dark World, there's
a chalkboard full of notes from Dr. Erik Selvig
and Dr. Jane Foster related to the possible
destruction of Earth due to the cosmic event
called the Convergence.
Eager fans noticed that the board contained
references to real-world science and Thor's
comic book lore.
The book Thor: The Dark World – The Art
of the Movie, released in the same year, has
a "laymanized" list of the items on the board.
The chalkboard mentions phenomena related
to black holes, how matter changes from one
state to another, electromagnetic forces,
and even string theory.
It also has some terms that comics readers
would doubtlessly recognize, such as 616 universe,
the Nexus of All Reality, and the Crossroads.
"It's simple.
Any questions?"
Captain America: The Winter Soldier introduced
some significant changes to the MCU.
For starters, it features Bucky as the Winter
Soldier and contains the first appearance
of the Falcon.
Perhaps most importantly, it reveals the sinister
truth behind S.H.I.E.L.D., which had become
infested with Hydra agents.
Nick Fury even has to fake his own death so
he can continue to work behind the scenes
and bring down the corrupted agency.
The Biblical passage engraved on his tombstone
ascribed to Ezekiel 25:17 will no doubt be
familiar to longtime fans of Samuel L. Jackson.
It's part of his dialogue in one of the most
iconic sequences from the famous 1994 crime
film Pulp Fiction.
"The path of the righteous is beset on all
sides by the inequities of the selfish and
the tyranny of evil men."
In an interview, directors Joe and Anthony
Russo shared that they decided on the verse
following the suggestion of the film's effects
supervisor.
For a brief period of time, there was speculation
that Stan Lee would not show up in Guardians
of the Galaxy due to the fact that he didn't
have a hand in their creation.
That's why fans were delighted when the film's
final cut did in fact contain a cameo from
The Man himself, complete with his signature
line "Excelsior" flashing on the screen in
a made-up alien language.
However, this was actually not the original
plan for Lee's cameo.
In an interview with director James Gunn,
he confirmed that initially, Lee was supposed
to be a specimen in the treasure room of the
Collector, and was supposed to throw a rude
gesture at Groot.
Gunn also said that he decided to scrap the
cameo from the film on his own, and that it
wasn't a studio mandate as rumored.
Avengers: Age of Ultron confirmed what many
audiences probably already knew about Tony
Stark: he had contingency plans in place if
the technology he frequently relied on ever
got disabled or compromised.
Following the transfer of his previous A.I.
assistant JARVIS into the body of Vision,
Stark was in need of a replacement.
Stark picks out FRIDAY, which becomes his
new guidance system.
However, fans also caught a glimpse of some
of the program cards that Stark didn't select
— and two of them bore names that were quite
familiar to Marvel comics fans.
One of the cards was labeled "JOCASTA," which
longtime readers of the Avengers' comic books
would know is the name of the robot that was
built by Ultron to be his partner.
Meanwhile, another card bore the name "TADASHI,"
a reference to the inventor of the A.I.
program behind Baymax in the Disney film Big
Hero 6.
The organization known as the Ten Rings has
been an established threat in the background
of the MCU since Iron Man.
However, what most fans may not know is that
in 2015, Ant-Man almost featured a blink-and-you'll-miss-it
reference to the terrorist faction in its
final cut.
In a commentary track for the film, Ant-Man
lead Paul Rudd and director Peyton Reed spill
the beans on a short scene that was omitted
from the movie.
After Pym Technologies CEO Darren Cross was
able to unlock the shrinking secrets of Pym
Particles, he immediately invited a group
of prospective buyers to a demonstration at the company.
In the deleted scene, a tattoo of the Ten
Rings was partially visible on the neck of
one of the potential investors, implying that
he was actually a member who wanted to get
his hands on the shrinking technology.
During the big showdown between Team Cap and
Team Tony at the airport in Germany, there's
a scene where Ant-Man and Captain America
use Pym Particles to turn a shrunken vehicle
into an expanding projectile.
For a few seconds, we get a glimpse of a unique
vehicle that should be instantly recognizable
to fans of the sitcom Arrested Development
— the Bluth Company stair car, missing the
company's logo on the side.
There's a good reason for this Easter egg:
the Russo brothers actually directed the pilot
of Arrested Development years before they
got into the business of directing MCU films.
As fans of the show would attest, the Bluth
family car wasn't exactly known for being
a smooth ride, and was even used in a few
wacky situations.
Let's just be thankful that it didn't cause
our heroes any trouble.
Doctor Strange featured a simple but clever
gag that was even used in the film's trailer.
When Stephen Strange arrives at the mystical
sanctuary in search of the Ancient One, her
student Mordo hands Strange a piece of paper
with the word "Shamballa" on it.
He asks what it's for, instantly assuming
that it's some sort of magical incantation.
Mordo's response?
"The WiFi password.
We're not savages."
Of course, because this is a Marvel movie,
you can bet that there's an interesting meaning
behind the word.
Published in 1986, the 23rd issue of the Marvel
Graphic Novel series features a story called
"Doctor Strange: Into Shamballa."
The book follows Dr. Strange as he travels
to the Ancient One's homeland and eventually
arrives at a magical moral quandary.
We won't spoil the rest of the story for you,
so that you can read it yourself.
When we see Stan the Man himself in "Guardians
Volume 2," he's wearing a spacesuit and sitting
on an asteroid.
He's not alone, though, as three Watchers
are listening to him talk about other adventures.
In other words, as one Twitter user put it:
"Stan Lee was canonically a Watcher informant,
and was playing the same character in every MCU movie."
Director James Gunn responded to this tweet
by admitting that "fan theories on Twitter"
were what prompted him to shoot this lighthearted
Stan Lee scene.
Kevin Feige himself acknowledged that the
late Marvel legend transcends the reality of the MCU.
As cool as it is, this scene did create a
bit of a continuity error, though.
Lee mentions being a FedEx delivery man, which
was his cameo in Captain America: Civil War
— a film that supposedly took place after
this one.
To his credit, Gunn acknowledged the error.
There's a scene in Spider-Man: Homecoming
where Peter Parker makes use of voice-changing
Stark technology to sound more intimidating
during an interrogation attempt.
Hilariously, it doesn't work on his target,
Aaron Davis.
"Deactivate interrogation mode."
This sequence is special for two reasons.
It teases the existence of another Spider-person,
and it's the culmination of a seven-year-old
campaign to put Donald Glover in a Spider-Man
movie.
Davis is, of course, the uncle of Miles Morales,
a.k.a.
the Spider-Man from the Ultimate universe
who now occupies the main Marvel Earth.
While the MCU's Davis doesn't say Morales'
name, he does mention that he has a nephew,
which is more than enough confirmation.
Back in 2010, when the Spider-Man reboot was
announced, #donald4spiderman went viral on
Twitter as Glover's fans pushed for him to
be considered for the lead role.
Of course, Andrew Garfield was eventually
cast as the webslinger.
Years later, Spider-Man: Homecoming director
Jon Watts swore to find a way to include Glover
in his Spider-film — and the rest, as they
say, is history.
In Thor: Ragnarok, Thor finds himself trapped
on the waste planet of Sakaar.
He becomes an unwilling participant in the
Contest of Champions.
The Grandmaster honors previous victors by
adding their sculptures on the tower of his
palace, which already has a few familiar faces
on it.
Eagle-eyed fans will have noticed the faces
of the mystical guardian the Man-Thing, the
war god Ares, and the Hulk villains Bi-Beast
and Dark-Crawler on the tower.
The most significant face there belongs to
none other than Beta Ray Bill, a horse-faced,
genetically modified member of the Korbinite
race and ally of Thor in the comics who wields
the powerful weapon Stormbreaker.
Kevin Feige revealed that Beta Ray Bill originally
had a slightly bigger role in Thor: Ragnarok,
but he was cut from the film.
As he told Crave Online,
"The feeling is, if you can't do [a character
like Beta Ray Bill] justice, do it later."
When T'Challa successfully subdues Ulysses
Klaue after a long chase, the villain begs
for mercy from the Wakandan king.
The superhero responds,
"Every breath you take is mercy from me."
It's an awesome line that, unbeknownst to
many moviegoers, is actually taken from New
Avengers Volume 3 Number 22, in which T'Challa
says it to Namor.
T'Challa already had a major ax to grind with
the arrogant Atlantean king before that issue,
as Namor once caused tremendous suffering
to many Wakandans as a result of what could
charitably be called a "petty grudge."
By the time the two kings found themselves
on the same team, their animosity had already
reached a boiling point, leading to a brutal
confrontation — and Namor's abrupt departure
from the team.
While audiences were happy to see Spider-Man
become formally integrated into the MCU with
the release of Spider-Man: Homecoming, the
apparent absence of his famous spider-sense
throughout the film became a serious point
of contention.
In a 2017 interview with Collider, Spider-Man:
Homecoming director Jon Watts explained the
decision to make the spider-sense less of
a presence in his film.
He said,
"The idea was, again, just you want to make
this movie be less about things you've already
seen before, and you've definitely already
seen a spider-sense sequence done extremely
well in Marc [Webb]'s and [Sam] Raimi's movies."
Despite Kevin Feige's confirmation that the
MCU version of Peter definitely possesses
a spider-sense and that they would "explore
it further down the line," fans still eagerly
awaited the day they'd witness this version
of the webslinger's spidey-sense in action.
That day eventually came in Avengers: Infinity
War — although Aunt May would eventually
refer to it by a different name.
"Please do not start calling it my 'Peter
tingle.'"
While most of Ant-Man and the Wasp explores
Scott's life under house arrest following
his participation in the Civil War battle,
it also introduces another size-changing superhero
from the comics.
Dr. Bill Foster, aka Goliath.
The movie doesn't really show Foster engaging
in heroics the same way Ant-Man and the Wasp
do, but it does mention his time working with
Dr. Hank Pym as a S.H.I.E.L.D. scientist.
In the scene where Dr. Foster is shown lecturing
to a classroom full of students, the chalkboard
behind him is full of mathematical equations.
It also has the word "matrix" written on it,
which, while a perfectly appropriate word
for the situation, can also be interpreted
as a reference to Fishburne's iconic role
as Morpheus in The Matrix.
Marvel legend Stan Lee was able to film a
few extra cameo appearances for a handful
of Marvel movies before his death in 2018.
One such Easter egg was for Captain Marvel.
During the sequence where Carol Danvers searches
for a Skrull agent in Los Angeles, she briefly
encounters Lee sitting by one of the windows.
The comic book writer is shown reading the
script for the 1995 film Mallrats, which he
also appeared in.
Speaking to The Hollywood Reporter, Mallrats
director Kevin Smith expressed his delight
at the nature of Lee's cameo in Captain Marvel,
and how it referenced his film.
"It was really kind of poetic and to hear
him saying his line, which, to be fair, was
some s–t that he would say in real life
all the time: 'Trust me, true believer.'
It was everything."
Smith must have been thrilled by the fact
that this was basically confirmation that
a version of him exists in the MCU.
One of the best things about Avengers: Endgame
is the way the main characters are able to
revisit some of their most iconic moments.
In the case of Steve Rogers, his visit to
the past allowed him to play things a bit
smarter in a situation very similar to that
elevator fight scene from The Winter Soldier.
This time, instead of beating up an elevator
full of Hydra agents, Rogers is able to bypass
a violent confrontation.
"Hail Hydra."
This works, and Rogers is seen seconds later
exiting the elevator with the scepter.
While this scene doubtlessly calls back to
Cap's elevator fight, it's also a sly reference
to a controversial 2016 comic.
Captain America: Steve Rogers Number 1, in
which Rogers is revealed as a secret Hydra
agent, a move that unsurprisingly riled fans
of the character.
That backlash was so fierce that Marvel had
to ask for readers to be patient while the
story unfolded.
When Peter Parker was officially introduced
to the MCU in Civil War, the character also
revealed a bit about his origin during a candid
conversation with Tony Stark.
Their talk made it clear that it was some
sort of grave personal tragedy that served
as Peter's wake-up call, making him realize
that he needs to "fight for the little guy."
This seemed to hint at his existence, but
there was no formal mention of Peter's uncle
Ben Parker in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
Fans didn't like the omission of arguably
the most important figure in Spider-Man's world.
Perhaps that's why the inclusion of the initials
"B.F.P."
on Peter's travel briefcase in Spider-Man:
Far From Home was so well-received: it's the
first real evidence that Uncle Ben existed
in the MCU, as well as a memorable Easter egg.
Black Widow gave MCU fans the opportunity
to know more about Natasha Romanoff's past
and adoptive family, as well as what she got
up to after the events of Civil War.
Interestingly, it also answered a question
that few people probably bothered to ask:
How did she get that cool-looking vest?
As it turns out, the vest belonged to Natasha's
sister and fellow Black Widow operative, Yelena Belova.
The younger Widow proudly shares to her big
sister, whom she has not seen for more than
two decades, that the vest is the first thing
she ever bought for herself.
After the final showdown, the two sisters
say their loving goodbyes, but not before
Belova leaves her vest with Romanoff as a
parting gift.
The touching gesture confirms that the bond
between them remains strong as ever.
Arguably, this also made Belova's reaction
to the news of Romanoff's death so much more
emotional and believable.
In the scene where Shang-Chi and Katy enter
the Golden Daggers Club, they are given a
quick tour of the place by the host.
While most MCU fans will have no doubt spotted
the fight between the Abomination and Wong,
there is another noteworthy fight featuring
two combatants deeply tied to MCU history.
In one of the cells where the fights take
place, a Black Widow who was rescued during
the events of the Black Widow movie is seen
squaring off against a soldier whose body
has been enhanced by the virus from Iron Man
3.
While the Widow appears to get the upper hand
by using her knives, she is later seen tending
to the soldier's wounds, reinforcing that
not all of the combatants in the club see
each other as enemies outside of the ring.
The second post-credits scene of Eternals
sets up the introduction of not one, but two
classic Marvel heroes.
After the disappearance of Sersi, her beau
Dane Whitman is seen opening a box containing
what appears to be a family heirloom: a sword
that has clearly been kept wrapped and hidden
for a long time.
This is, of course, the Ebony Blade, the weapon
that Whitman wields as the medieval-themed
superhero the Black Knight.
As the nervous human attempts to touch the
blade, he hears a voice saying,
"Sure you're ready for that, Mr. Whitman?"
The scene abruptly ends without revealing
who the mysterious voice belongs to.
In an interview with Empire Online, director
Chloé Zhao confirmed that the line was spoken
by Mahershala Ali, the MCU's version of Blade.
She said,
"I gotta say, in just the little time I spent
with Mahershala, I can't wait for the Blade
movie to come out."
Given the sheer amount of nostalgic references
incorporated into Spider-Man: No Way Home,
it's hard to choose the "best" among all of
its Easter eggs.
For instance, the entire conversation between
the three Peters during the climactic battle
is, in itself, one Easter egg after another.
The bit where Andrew Garfield offers to "crack"
Maguire's back to relieve its stiffness is
a clever nod to Maguire's infamous back problems
during the development of Spider-Man 2.
The filmmakers even managed to sneak in a
scene where the three Peters recreate that
famous pointing meme from the 1960s Spider-Man
cartoon.
However, if we had to pick just one Easter
egg as the best of the lot, it would have
to be how Garfield's Spider-Man saves MJ from
falling to her death.
As fans who saw The Amazing Spider-Man 2 will
recall, he was unable to save the love of
his life, Gwen Stacy, who died in a strikingly
similar situation.
It nearly drove him to hang up the webs for
good — and by saving the girlfriend of an
alternate-reality version of himself, he gained
some much-needed closure.
Garfield says a lot with his face alone in
this scene, one of the standout moments in the movie.
When Doctor Strange and America Chavez go
multiverse-hopping, they become stranded on
Earth-838, where an alternate version of Strange
seemingly sacrificed his life to defeat Thanos.
However, the traveling duo are detained in
the Baxter Foundation, where the mainstream
MCU Strange learns the horrific truth about
his counterpart's death.
Here, Strange also meets the Illuminati, a
covert group of heroes who secretly determine
the best course of action against major threats.
The Illuminati of Earth-838 is made up of
Mordo, Captain Marvel, the Inhuman king Black
Bolt, Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four,
Captain Carter, and their leader, Professor Charles Xavier.
This incarnation of Professor X sits in his
yellow hoverchair from the '90s comics.
Additionally, when he is introduced, a brief
segment of the iconic X-Men: The Animated Series theme plays.
In one scene of Thor: Love and Thunder, Zeus
uses his godly powers to "flick" away a restrained Thor's garments.
He overdoes it, though, which leaves Thor
thoroughly exposed to the stunned crowd.
We get a good view of Thor from behind, which
shows that he has a big tattoo on his back
to honor his brother Loki.
Right next to it is another tattoo shaped
like a roll of parchment, bearing some of
the names of Thor's loved ones who have passed
away.
His mom and dad are there, as are Heimdall,
Tony, and Natasha.
Interestingly, according to director Taika
Waititi, this Easter egg was cut from Thor: Ragnarok.
However, they deemed it too good to waste,
so they made it bigger for Thor: Love and Thunder.